[Music]
on this Friday night Twitter's
ever-changing rule book how the latest
round of suspensions has users
scrambling and Regulators on alert the
move sets a dangerous precedent
and the new warning for parents about
another social media giant
another round of Russian airstrikes
pound power plants the bitter cold and
uncomfortable reality tests Ukraine's
resolve waves of Devastation the massive
cleanup effort underway after a giant
aquarium crumbles plus the Canadian Atop
The slam poetry World a swing that only
knows the Embrace of wind how this
Global Champion hopes to raise the
profile of a lesser-known art form
global national with para Nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us
since Elon Musk one of the richest
people in the world bought Twitter two
months ago users have been feeling
regular Whiplash after frequent changes
to its policy that seemed to happen on
the fly but this latest controversy
surrounding the social media giant goes
deeper when musk a self-described free
speech absolutist originally announced
he wanted to buy Twitter he tweeted his
hopes that even his worst critics stay
on the platform because that's what Free
Speech means now musk has suspended the
accounts of a number of high-profile
journalists who cover the company while
reinstating accounts for several white
supremacists and other Peddlers of hate
speech Eric Sorensen reports when he
took over Twitter Elon Musk suggested
let that sink in but does he now risk
taking Twitter's reputation down the
drain his latest controversial move
stems from a Twitter account and links
posted to it that tracked his private
jet he tweeted criticizing me is totally
fine but doxing IEP posting personal
details of my real-time location and
endangering my family is not he then
suspended several accounts of prominent
journalists even though he's described
Twitter as the Town Square and himself
as a freedom of speech absolutist well I
think it's very important for
uh there to be an inclusive arena for
free speech that they are able to speak
freely within the bounds of the law but
the journalists were within the bounds
of the law one is Aaron rubar all of the
people who were banned beyond the
commonality of sharing this Facebook
link the other thing we have in common
is that we've all been critical of Elon
the suspensions add to the perception
that musk supports free speech for some
including a white supremacist whose
account was reinstated but not for those
like journalists he disagrees with the
European Union has now threatened
sanctions against Twitter even the
United Nations reacted because it views
the social media giant as a worldwide
platform for factual information the
move sets a dangerous precedent at a
time when a journalist all over the
world are facing censorship of physical
threats and even even worse musk
undaunted jumped onto Twitter live last
night where journalists were discussing
it all including some who were suspended
from Twitter everyone's going to be
treated the same they're not special
because you're a journalist afterwards
Twitter live was disabled to many musk
is deeply damaging what he spent 44
billion US dollars to own if he believes
as he claims to that Twitter is going to
be a kind of a public forum for all
opinions he's clearly given the lie to
that that's not what he wants he wants
it simply to be a reflection of his own
ideas and nobody else's Twitter is a
private Enterprise so musk can ban who
he wants but his personal interventions
have come at a cost the stock price of
Tesla his big e-vehicle Enterprise has
plunged and musk has lost his crown as
the world's richest man something else
to let sink in Eric Sorensen Global News
Toronto
let's now zero in on those stocks today
Tesla's shares slumped once again to
around 150 U.S compare that to when they
closed a trading day in January just shy
of 400 the company's value has fallen
from over one trillion dollars to below
500 billion it hasn't helped that musk
sold 23 billion dollars worth of Tesla
stocks since April many believe it was
to fund his expensive Twitter
acquisition
and his Twitter faces scrutiny over it's
blocking another platform Tick Tock
faces accusations of not doing enough to
protect vulnerable teens from harmful
content researchers in the UK says
content linked to eating disorders and
self-harm is pushed on teens at an
alarmingly rapid pace and they want
parents to know the risks Jackson Frasco
reports
millions of teens hold Tick-Tock in the
palm of their hand researchers worry the
app has an increasingly powerful grip on
them Tick Tock is this sort of
weapons-grade uh version of social media
in which it aggressively ferociously
pushes new content constantly
a study from the non-profit Center for
countering digital hate found Tick-Tock
bombards young teens with potentially
harmful content they set up eight test
accounts as 13 year old girls in Canada
the US UK and Australia where the
average young user spends 80 minutes per
day on the app we found that
eating disorder content was being served
up within minutes self-harm content
within two and a half minutes and every
39 seconds these test accounts on the
recommended for you page were getting
harmful content ccdh says its research
found videos relating to eating
disorders had 13 billion views alone
that included potentially harmful
material alongside stories of recovery
and support co-mingled under the same
hashtags we also know that the platforms
like Instagram and Tick Tock that are
really focused on like visual rep
representation where kids are comparing
themselves to other people tend to have
worse effects particularly for girls in
a statement a spokesperson for tick tock
questioned the study saying this
activity and resulting experience does
not reflect genuine Behavior or viewing
experiences of real people we regularly
consult with health experts remove
violations of our policies and provide
access to supportive resources for
anyone in need Tick Tock also says it
regularly removes the types of content
identified in the report if it violates
Community guidelines
[Music]
Tick Tock is of particular concern both
because of its popularity and because
its Chinese parent company offers a far
more regulated version of the platform
in China with time limits and
educational content for young teens I
think it's very striking that they are
feeding American children a much
different product
that has opened Tick Tock up to new
levels of scrutiny as governments weigh
whether it's time to end the
self-regulation of social media Jackson
prosco Global News Washington
many people in and around Ottawa spent
the day digging out after a heavy and
wet snowfall
school bus routes across Ottawa and
Eastern Ontario were canceled today
although schools stayed open a snowfall
warning is still in effect for the
capitol with Environment Canada calling
for 20 to 30 centimeters of snow by
Saturday morning
after the liberal government announced
it's delaying the expansion of this
country's medically assisted dying laws
many gave a sigh of relief starting in
March people whose sole underlying
condition is a mental disorder would
have been eligible to end their lives as
Ottawa puts the plan on pause tariya
isri speaks to some on the front lines
of this deeply personal debate
George of rakis is a talented painter
but her true passion is psychology and
she has a unique perspective as both a
therapist and patient I'm broken by
George of rakis raucous began suffering
from depression at 23 years old but it
took two decades before she got the
right diagnosis I was having a major
depressive episode and I didn't
understand what was happening to me and
I just wanted to die once rackets
learned she had bipolar disorder she
received the proper treatment and
medication but she worries about what
could have happened if medical
assistance in dying or made had been
available in her Darkest Hours when she
felt she had nowhere else to go the
thing is if they had offered me
something like that you know because you
know suffering years of suffering
who I may have said yes maybe a year ago
Dr roccas you have five minutes vraqis
testified before a parliamentary
committee that Canada should not open
made up to people with mental illness
they would have been eligible in March
until the federal government backtracked
we know we need to get this right the
Liberals are planning to extend the
deadline after psychiatrists across the
country warned the Health Care system
was not ready including Dr Simon Hatcher
at the Ottawa General Hospital we can't
be both the foundation of Mental Health
Services but we can't fund your death Dr
Hatcher says there are still too many
unknowns what are the rules around
deciding what what makes something
irreversible it's not clear how long the
extension will last because the Liberals
still have to table legislation in the
new year but the Justice Minister says
he has no intentions on backing away
from the plan we have rigorous
eligibility criteria supporters insist
there are proper safeguards and argue
the delay will only prolong suffering a
lot of people mental disorders will yet
again feel like they're being told by
their government being told by their
society that their diseases aren't as
painful as those with physical disorders
instead of trying to you know find ways
to well
so we die with dignity
maybe we should focus on helping us live
with dignity a life and death debate as
Canada prepares to enter new legal
territory tariya isri Global News Ottawa
the federal government released some
documents earlier this week confirming
that the country's most senior
bureaucrats were well aware of attempts
by the Chinese government to interfere
in the 2019 election though senior
bureaucrats work in the privy Council
Office or PCO that's one of the most
important offices when it comes to
advising the Prime Minister but what
role does the PCO actually play on a
daily basis let's bring in our chief
political correspondent David Aiken for
that David tell us more about the work
those bureaucrats do and how the
intelligence they get makes its way to
decision makers like the PM well for the
documents released this week contain a
significant amount of top secret
information and as a result the
documents are heavily censored now we
know they reference potential election
interference by China but it's
impossible to say where the PCO obtained
that intelligence about Chinese
interference nor is it clear what if
anything the government did with that
information we set up specifically for
this purpose and elections oversight
panel to make sure that foreign
interference did not have an impact on
our election on our electoral processes
and in both 2019 and 2021 Canadians can
be reassured that our election Integrity
held still
the Chinese election interference
combined with evidence heard during the
emergencies act commission provides new
insights into the working of the privy
Council Office even as it raises new
questions about how information gets
from PCO intelligence officials to
politicians the key official is the
country's most senior civil servant
known as the clerk of the privy Council
the current office holder is Janice
charette I'm also
the advisor on all matters that would be
for be before the Prime Minister for his
consideration decision in other words if
the PM knows about it the clerk knows
about it I get briefed up on it all the
time and our intelligence and security
agencies continue to act responsibly and
ensure that we're minimizing and
avoiding any serious impact on Canadians
another PCO official the National
Security and intelligence advisor does
those briefings her name is Jody Thomas
but any advice from Thomas also goes
through the clerk first I sign it off as
the National Security advisor but she
also reviews it and signs it before it
heads goes to the Prime Minister
verbal briefs cabinet briefs discussions
with prime minister the clerk is in the
room the PCO might best be described as
the bureaucratic twin to the pmo the
prime minister's office together the two
offices are the most powerful and
important organizations in the Canadian
government but as we saw during the
emergencies act commission and again
with the paper trail on Chinese election
interference there is much about the
work of the PCO and the pmo that remains
concealed from public scrutiny pharah
David Aiken in Ottawa thank you David
keeping Spirits high as air strikes rain
down coming up how ukrainians came
together in the face of another major
Russian offensive
[Music]
Ukrainian folk songs and some dancing
helped lift Spirits in a Kiev subway
station today residents were taking
shelter as Russia pounded Ukraine with
dozens of missiles
Moscow is accused of weaponizing winter
targeting Ukraine's power grid in
Relentless attacks Heating and
electricity in at least four cities is
down as temperatures dip below freezing
across much of the country our Europe
bureau chief Crystal gamensing Reports
trains ground to a halt and the capital
giving ukrainians a safe place to
shelter as the rocket attack warning
siren Wales from above ground the
muffled thud of explosions
our anti-missile system works quite well
but due to the high quantity of cruise
missiles
shot by Russian federations launched by
Russian Federation we still face some
difficulties difficulties like the loss
of power heat and water Ukrainian
officials say Russia again targeted
energy infrastructure sites this time
roughly nine power stations were knocked
offline affecting about 50 percent of
the energy grid
in harkeev there was a total blackout
but locals got to work at what's called
an invincibility Center
we heard explosions the power went out
people need to be fed we are here
cooking on a wood stove
[Applause]
generators air defense and the will of
the people three things Ukraine's Deputy
interior Minister says we'll see them
through these dark and bitterly cold
days attacking our energy infrastructure
making people suffer during the winter
time that's about genocide of our nation
but I must admit that our moral is
extremely strong and we will never
surrender
with that fight comes death and
destruction in kivari several lives were
lost and more than a dozen people were
injured as night fell Crews were still
digging through the rubble of what's
left of a residential apartment building
one child was unaccounted for his
parents and a 64 year old woman had been
killed
Crystal commencing Global News London
after nearly eight Decades of pacifism
Japan's prime minister announced the
country's biggest military buildup since
the second world war Japan will spend
320 billion dollars more than double its
current defense budget to increase the
capacity for its self-defense forces
including a plan to buy long-range
missiles the plan would make Japan the
third largest military spender in the
world after the U.S and China the Prime
Minister says The Growing Power of China
along with threats from North Korea and
Russia puts Japan in a turning point in
history
[Music]
Fish Out of Water ahead The Aquatic
disaster which swept a wave of debris
onto the streets of Berlin
[Music]
King Charles showed off his dance moves
while enjoying some pre-hanukkah
celebrations at a Jewish Community
Center in London each year the center
hosts a reception for Holocaust
Survivors and community members ahead of
the Festival of Lights which begins at
sundown on Sunday
former Royal staffer Susan Hessey and
ngozi Fulani met today at Buckingham
Palace for an in-person apology Hussey
apologized for repeatedly asking Fulani
where she was from during a palace
reception last month fellani was born in
Britain and is the founder of a domestic
abuse survivors charity Hussey is Prince
William's godmother and was a close
friend of the late Queen tragedy struck
a French suburb after a deadly early
morning fire ripped through an apartment
Block near Leon at least 10 people are
dead five of the victims are children
believed to be between 3 and 15 years
old it took 170 firefighters to
extinguish the Flames the cause is under
investigation
a huge cleanup is underway in Berlin
after the world's largest freestanding
cylindrical aquarium burst the giant
tank was 16 meters tall and it housed
more than 1500 exotic fish Witnesses say
the centerpiece of the hotel exploded
overnight without warning creating a
flood of more than one million liters of
water
two people were hurt by flying glass and
almost all the fish died the hotel is
temporarily closed some 350 guests have
been moved to other accommodations
[Music]
the art of a slam next the Canadian poet
pushing his unique craft into the
Limelight
[Music]
three two one
engine ignition
liftoff for a mission to conduct an
unprecedented survey of the Earth's
surface water a joint U.S French
satellite is called SWAT for surface
water and ocean topography and one of
its primary objectives is to help us
understand how oceans and other bodies
of water absorb heat and carbon dioxide
and the aim is to improve long-term
climate change forecasting
a Canadian has done the country proud in
a major competition that demands equal
parts Artistry confidence and precision
poet edley lardy is back from Brazil
after walking away with top honors from
an international poetry slam
championship and as Ross Lord reports
the new champion from Hamilton Ontario
hopes the achievement will shine a
greater Spotlight on a lesser-known art
form
foreign
poetry is an art form unlike any other
one that Eddie larti has come to master
when you're sandwiched between
nightmares and nightlife every toast
becomes a prayer winning an
international poetry slam competition in
Brazil against 13 other poets so
um
where I get to report on the things that
are happening in front of me I get to
dictate and I get a spotlight that's
that's placed on me but I get to to
Showcase it on the things that's
happening around me largely build on the
momentum we gained from winning the
Canadian poetry slam in the spring on
the strength of poems like this one
called gentrification there's a Catholic
hurts being remade in the image of a
condo a hungry collection plate an
overdue light bill residents drowned in
both debt and baptism the church was
built on top of a graveyard and even
here the ghost can no longer afford to
rest in peace at the Brazil Championship
his word smithing even cut across a
language divide it was interpreted in
American Sign Language captioned in
English Portuguese and Spanish an artist
who's considered a love poet
transcending boundaries I'm always
trying to make people feel good and and
make people feel loved and connected to
whatever their purpose is Marty's
success could also mean greater exposure
for slam poetry there's no hate language
and you have three minutes and 10
seconds no props no musical instruments
except for the sounds your body can make
all original work original work that
Eddie larti hopes to see more of in
Canada strong enough to hold a cup I
know the cop has no hold on me
Ross Lord Global News
and that's global national for this
Friday I'm Farah Nasser tonight's your
Canada is this giant snowflake in
Schreiber Ontario the artistic display
is made from Snowshoe tracks thanks for
watching until tomorrow take care of
yourselves and each other good night
thank you